bonjour à toutes les deux merci beaucoup
d'être ce matin en direct dans la
matinée dans le dernier france pour
parler du harcèlement scolaire journée
nationale aujourd'hui je commence par
vous sandrine fallait vous avez perdu
votre fils christopher en 2017 est ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter les
circonstances
oui tout à fait christopher et c'est dès
le 17 avril 2010 est
à l'âge de 16 ans il a subi le
harcèlement scolaire dans son
établissement
sur les réseaux sociaux il était traité
de [ __ ] d'euros
parce que justement il faisait du cheval
c'était sa passion il être maréchal
ferrant
dans sa classe il a subi des
humiliations pour lui a demandé de
descendre son pantalon on lui a demandé
il va des défis en fait comme faire des
fellations
christopher youri écrit sur un cahier et
aucun déposé plainte
et ce dossier
classé sans suite comme malheureusement
son
témoignage très fort ce matin qu message
vous vous vous souhaitez relayé
aujourd'hui
nous aimerions que écouté
que les gens écoutent leurs enfants
parce que il parle alors pas avec des
mots en disant je suis harcelé mais avec
des mots ça peut être des maux de ventre
ça peut être une baisse de note
ça peut être un changement de
comportement les spurs étaient très très
très agressif à la maison ce qui n'était
pas là j'avais parlé de ces harcèlements
votre fils
non justement
cgt
et
nous on n'a pas compris catherine la
trompette c'est un témoignage parmi des
centaines d'autres évidemment vous vous
êtes attaché beaucoup à vous avez eu un
cas également dans votre famille et vous
êtes attachez vous à cadre législatif il
ya une loi qui existe depuis deux ans
contre le harcèlement scolaire et on
voit le problème continue pourquoi
il ya une loi qui existe depuis deux ans
fait depuis deux ans il est inscrit dans
le code de l'éducation que chaque enfant
a droit à une scolarité sans harcèlement
mais ça n'est pas allé au delà c'est à
dire c'est un droit inscrit fictif
virtuel qui n'a pas encore son
application réelle dans les
établissements c'est à dire que avec le
projet de loi qui s'annonce là et qui
devrait je l'espère vivement être être
votées à la fin de ce mois de novembre
ce droit deviendra un droit réel puisque
ça imposera aux établissements de mettre
en place systématiquement un plan de
prévention du harcèlement de façon à
réellement protéger les enfants parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce droit existe mais
aucun établissement est soumis à la
moindre obligation ça reste du volo tard
volontariat certains établissements
mettre des choses en place mais les
cellules d'écouté en place mais des
organisations des procédures qui
permettent à la jeune victime d'être
prises en charge
mais ces établissements se comptent sur
les doigts d'une main
demain après-demain à la fin de ce mois
comment le projet de loi porté par le
député erwan balanant
serait adoptée ça changerait tout on est
tous là signifierait que chaque
établissement devrait mettre les moyens
en place pour protéger chaque élève
chaque étudiant depuis la maternelle
jusqu'à limoux cité
de la violence et du harcèlement et la
cour oui pardonnez moi je vous coupe la
parole mais qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre
en place concrètement à la fois pour
aider les victimes à libérer leur parole
quel plan de prévention comment est ce
qu'on peut faire
il existe de nombreux outils pour
prendre en charge le harcèlement c'est à
dire prendre en charge la victime quand
elle parle quand il existe une cellule
d'écouté qui la met en confiance et qui
lui permet de révéler ces mots parce
qu'il extrêmement difficile de révéler
les ché il est beaucoup plus facile pour
une victime de révéler comment c'est
fait en un impact sur sa santé ça y est
la première chose mais c'est sain c'est
canteloup heures seulement et déjà
identifiés ce qui est intéressant c'est
que cette nouvelle loi va imposer aux
établissements de mettre en place un
dispositif pour empêcher que le
harcèlement arrive et ça il existe un
dispositif
à notre connaissance il n'en existe
qu'un au monde il a été développé par
l'université des sciences de la famille
en belgique à mons ce dispositif confie
à faire révéler dans chaque classe les
émotions que ressentent les élèves et
des étudiants alors évidemment on ne
fait pas révélé les émotions de la même
façon quand un élève à 4 ans ou quand il
en a 17 mai
solea va pouvoir s'exprimer devant
devant toute une classe oui oui tu peux
parce que c'est à c'est un espace de
parole protégé qui est mis en place de
façon régulière à raison d'une fois par
semaine d'une fois par quinzaine et vous
avez raison si est un espace très
protégé c'est à dire que la parole à une
relance alors en quelque sorte on est
tout à fait mais il eut le ferai parce
qu'il ne serait pas seulement face à ses
harceleurs il le fait quand je ne parle
pas de conditionnel qu'on a déjà mis en
place ce système dans de nombreux
établissements dans des milliers
d'établissements en belgique quelques
dizaines en france il le fait il prend
la parole devant ses harceleurs parce
qu'il sait qu'il est soutenu par le
reste de la classe on entend souvent
quand on est harcelé c'est tout à fait
normal on pense souvent que l'ensemble
de la classe et contre soi s'il fait
très chaud défaut il y à quelques contre
soit inscrit aucun doute mais la
majorité de la classe n'est pas en
accord avec les insultes et les
moqueries le rejet mais par peur ces
élèves qui ne sont pas en accord ne
s'exprime pas il vient dans cet espace
de parole protéger alors évidemment ça
doit respecter certaines règles ça ne se
met pas en place comme ça c'est vraiment
un dispositif qui s'installe qui
régulait par la gu c'est peut-être la
grande différence le clip disent
qu'aujourd'hui on ne demande pas aux
élèves de réguler et de protéger la
parole et l'adulte qui le fait et cette
régulation met en confiance
l'enfant qui n'est pas encore harceler
attention que vous présente l'un
dispositif et empêche le harcèlement
c'est à dire c'est un enfant qui ne
violente et ponctuellement qui commence
à être rejetée mais cet enfant n'est pas
encore
exclu totalement de la classe par
l'ensemble des élèves en est au début
j'allais dire de l'installation de ce
harcèlement l'aïd est encore en position
d'exprimer ses émotions des émotions
désagréables et l'on ne va pas chercher
un coupable mais aussi ça qui fait la
différence avec ce que nous avons
l'habitude d'expérimenter en france on
ne recherche pas des coupables on
recherche des solutions comment la
classe peut-être comporter comment
certains élèves de la classe peuvent-ils
agir pour que l'enfant qui ressent des
émotions fortement désagréable et bien
ne les ressentent plus quelle solution
l'ensemble de la classe peut mettre en
place et quand on parle solution on
renverse on casse l'effet pouvoir j'ai
installé par quoi 1 deux bonnes heures
trois bonnes heures il faut pas pensiez
que les lifts 15 harceleur martelage
s'il en existe un 2 c'est le grand
maximum allait évidemment quand le
phénomène s'installe le nombre de
harceleur va grossir mais quand on est
on va leur pardon il nous reste très peu
de temps jour exxon fallait s'exprimer
et réagissent justement à vos
propositions
c'est ce qui n'a pas ce qui n'a pas été
fait justement dents au sein de la
classe de christopher
c'était plusieurs harceleur c'était les
professeurs qui étaient là et qu'ils
écoutaient qui voyait ce qui se passait
et qui n'a rien n'a été fait au niveau
de la direction c'est pareil et
justement grâce à ces nouvelles lois
grâce à ce que catherine viennent dire
ce qui se passe en belgique christopher
serait peut-être encore là et vous
voulez que nos jeunes qui sont partis on
a quand même vu 21 là en moins de moins
d'un an nous on a créé une
groupe de parents
d'enfants qui sont partis les parents et
on est tous là on se demande ce qui va
se passer et si tous avaient été mis en
place ne se répétait encore la wii et en
ce qui concerne le corps enseignant
quel a été votre expérience avec eux est
ce qu'il doit être d'avant ils doivent
être davantage sensibilisés aujourd'hui
les professeurs aussi à ce fléau
sensibiliser je pense qu'ils le sont
depuis des années depuis 2014 des
mesures de sensibilisation des mises en
place dans les établissements là il faut
passer j'allais dire à l'étape d'après
non seulement ils méritent d'être ils
doivent être sensibilisés mais ils
doivent aussi mettre en place un
dispositif pour améliorer le nez le
climat classe parce que 99% des
situations de harcèlement s'initie au
sein de la classe au sein de la classe
pas sur les réseaux sociaux dans la
classe et c'est bien dans la classe
était bien le groupe classe on peut
justement modifier son comportement
améliorer les relations pour que plus
aucun enfant ne souffre d'être dans une
place parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le cas
l'unesco estime à la moitié des célèbes
qui souffre donc qui voient leur santé
intérêt dans ce qui surprirent c'est pas
juste je me sens pas bien non je ne vais
pas bien ma santé est altérée par une
ambiance de places délétère humiliante
repoussante où je tente voire insultante
voir frappant très court katrina
trompette sur le volet pénale le volet
sanction faut-il sanctionner ce type de
comportement pénalement
oui il faut qu'il joue sanctionner ce
type de comportement parce qu'il
représente un délit sans aucun doute
mais là où la loi doit encore progresser
et qui elle va devoir aussi sanctionner
les établissements qui reste sourd qui
refuse de mettre en place des actions et
de sensibilisation et prévention
parce que malheureusement si elles
existent encore et tant que ça existera
bien on risquera de voir nos enfants
détruit leur santé voire de mettre fin à
leurs jours malheureusement merci à
toutes les deux un grand merci sandrine
fallait d'avoir accepté de témoigner ce
matin sur rtl france merci avoue
catherine la trompette je le répète vous
êtes toutes les deux coprésidentes de
mars helmand